ein Bericht sorgt aktuell für Aufregung
nämlich aus dem US-Kongress der ganz
offiziell sagt er es ist davon
auszugehen dass das Virus hier sehen
wird das Deckblatt dieses Berichts des
US-Kongresses tatsächlich aus einem
Labor in Wuhan stammt
wie stehen Sie dazu folgen Sie dieser
Theorie und vor allen Dingen was
bedeutet das jetzt für Sie für die
deutsche Politik wenn nach und nach das
eben nicht mehr in den Bereich der
Gerüchte der
Verschwörungstheorie lebt sondern wenn
der US-Kongress da tatsächlich ein
Stempel drauf macht und sagt ja davon
gehen wir aus stammt aus dem
Chinesischen Labor aus Wuhan
soweit ich weiß ist das jetzt noch ein
Bericht der von einer der Parteien
angefordert wurde und dann abgegeben
bitte das ist jetzt ganz entscheidend
sie haben völlig Recht diese Bericht
wird dort diskutiert dann muss natürlich
auch mal die US-Regierung als Ganzes
dazu ein Statement abgeben das würde
dann sehr interessieren und auch
Deutschland muss diesen Bericht genau
studieren und dann seine Analysen daraus
ziehen und möglich über mögliche
Konsequenzen diskutieren ich würde mich
da jetzt noch zurückhalten wenn das so
wäre wäre das schon eine sehr sehr
spannende herausfordernde Situation
insbesondere deswegen weil es dazu keine
Äußerung gegeben hat bislang aber das
muss jetzt mal abschließend geklärt
werden auf jeden Fall wird dieser steht
für erhebliche Diskussion sorgen für
Diskussionen und vor allen Dingen für
Schadenersatzforderungen also das liegt
ja jetzt auf der Hand wenn sich eben es
wurde ganz lange als
Verschwörungstheorie abgetan von
deutscher Politik von deutschen
Wissenschaftler auch von Herrn Drosten
unter anderem und jetzt rückt das aber
immer mehr in den in den Bereich ja
Stempel drauf alle Hinweise deuten
darauf hin das heißt das verändert ja
völlig die politische Debatte um
Schadenersatzforderungen
ich würde mal sagen wir sehen diesen
Bericht den ich selber ja nicht gelesen
habe bislang ich habe über die
Berichterstattung jetzt darüber fahren
und deswegen wird es natürlich sehr
akribisch genau analysiert werden sowohl
noch mal der US-Regierung ist schon
wichtig auch was der Präsident der
Vereinigten Staaten und seine Regierung
dazu sagt ist es die dem offizielle
Meinung der USA dann muss das über die
WHO auch diskutiert werden auch dann
Stellungnahme ist wichtig und der
Bundesregierung und dann wenn diese
Ergebnisse gesichert wären dann hat es
sicherlich eine weitere Diskussion zur
Folge also
ich weiß dass man da aus dem ersten
Impuls heraus gerne mehr fordern möchte
aber erstmal eins nach dem anderen
diskutieren stimmt es wirklich in
welcher Form in welchem Umfang und dann
sind wir weiter aber wenn diese Frage
nochmal abschließend so lange im Bereich
der Verschwörungstheorie war dann haben
wir uns doch offenbar bisher nicht
abschließend damit oder nicht
ausreichend damit beschäftigt wir hatten
ja auch selber seitens der
Bundesregierung mal so ein Bericht
anfertigen können
oder im Parlament
ja gut der Zugang erfolgte über andere
Möglichkeiten also da wird sie einfach
sehr spannend sein wie diese Bericht
bewertet wird ob man den selbst als
glaubwürdig einstuft wird das überhaupt
keine Zweifel daran schön im Gegenteil
aber das muss jetzt alles mal eingestuft
werden ich würde es einfach mal
vorschlagen das ist etwas für die für
für dieses Gespräch in zwei oder drei
Wochen okay trotzdem wollten sie diese
Frage überhaupt geklärt haben bisher
wollte die deutsche Politik diese Frage
geklärt haben war sie dran interessiert
oder sicher ist ja ganz entscheidend ist
ja ganz entscheidend woher kommt Corona
woher kommt Corona und durch was ist es
verursacht worden ist ja ganz
entscheidend